[Music]
it's really impossible to remember
all of the fake and frivolous
controversies that the internet has
given us
that's part of the fake and frivolous
package i suppose they're all so
forgettable but one such controversy has
stood out and will be remembered at
least by me that's the controversy
surrounding the man who is known now
as being dead now some background john
roderick is a musician
podcast host who became infamous on
twitter last month
after he tweeted out a thread detailing
his daughter's experience with a can
opener
now in a long very unnecessarily long
story he explained that his daughter
wanted to open a can of beans
but rather than do it for her he he had
he had her figure it out for herself
as a kind of teaching opportunity and he
says it took her hours
hours trying to open the can before she
finally did it
and he posted this as sort of a
congratulations to himself
for being a good dad but the world and
twitter
didn't see it that way the thread went
viral people were
outraged they accused him of abuse
psychological abuse emotional abuse
physical abuse
they said that he was starving his
daughter they said he's a horrible
person etc and so forth
then they started digging up his old
tweets of course and next thing you know
he's uh not only a bad father
abusive but racist too so he's racist
and abusive
all this stuff happened and eventually
he apologized and deactivated his
account but it was too late meanwhile
back in realityville it's obvious that
the story was an exaggeration
the girl was not working on a can of
beans for hours give me a break
and even if she was it's not abuse
presumably
she's not malnourished he is feeding her
he never said that her continued access
to food was predicated
on her ability to get the can open he
didn't say that so even if he was being
a jerk
about the can whatever calling that
abuse is insane
and look i i have never
um been in a situation where my kids
were trying to open a can for six hours
so
i've never done that but all of us as
parents we have
moments where our kids ask us to do
something
and uh and we could do it for them it
would be very easy for us to do but for
whatever reason
we just don't feel like doing it and so
we say no look you figure that out for
yourself i'm not doing it
so all parents have moments like that
and it's good to have moments like that
it's good for the for the kid to have to
figure something out
um six hours opening a can is a little
bit excessive
but even so so there was no abuse here
uh and being dad's real crime if he
committed one was in being a tool who
tries to
you know brag about his own excellent
parenting on the internet
or what he thinks is excellent parenting
and if that's
the crime then that's the one he
committed but that doesn't make him a
child abuser right
or or so i thought an update on this
story from reason written by lenoir
skinezy it says roderick recently
divulged a new wrinkle in the story
which makes it clear that it was not
just an online kerfuffle for his
afternoon of bean withholding roderick
actually earned a visit from the child
protective services
in roderick on the line his weekly
podcast with merlin mann
roderick said a dozen people reported me
to cps and they were obligated to come
interview my family and interrogate my
daughter
thankfully the cps visit went well they
were wonderful said roderick and they
were just doing their jobs
apparently one investigator told
roderick's daughter for about an hour or
rather
spoke to roderick's daughter for about
an hour privately asking questions
like what do you like about your dad and
what do you not like about your dad
roderick's daughter told him about this
afterward turns out she doesn't like the
fact that he gets tired of playing
legos faster than he than she does
okay so that's that's a report from
reason child protective services
because he made his daughter open a can
of beans on her own
this is the kind of thing that keeps
parents up at night right this this
right here not because we've had we have
similar family drama involving cans of
beans and not because we're abusive
but because cps can be summoned to our
homes
very easily and for the most trivial of
reasons and once they show up
your parental rights are on the line of
course
they're not suspended now so cps does
not have the right to enter your home
without permission
or to speak to your your child without
permission and that's something that
parents
i think a lot of parents don't realize
and um
cps i think counts on parents not
realizing that and they show up and
knock on the door and they say can we
come in can we talk to your kid
and parents because they are scared and
and they feel like their backs against
the wall now they'll say sure come in
and
you don't have to do that and it's a
mistake
to let cps in in that situation because
think about it they're
according to um john roderick they're
sitting down and talking to her
his daughter for an hour saying things
like what do you
these are fishing leading kinds of
questions
what do you not like about your dad
who knows what kind of thing a kid will
say in response to that
kids are imaginative kids that
they don't really understand what the
consequences are they don't really know
what's going on
a kid could be you know you could cps
could come in at a moment when the child
is angry at the parent not because
they're being abused but because kids
get angry about you know not being
allowed to watch tv when they want to or
something
and who knows what they'll say so the
minute you say sure sit down and talk to
my kid for an hour
that could go anywhere i mean that could
be the last time you see your kid for a
long time
depending on how that goes um but
even if you don't let the cps in they
can they can go and
they're not going to leave you alone
after that they can go get a court order
they can continue harassing if they
choose once cps is in your life
it can be very difficult to get them out
and just the simple
fact that they showed up at your door
carries a stigma that may never go away
even if again you're totally innocent as
the article in reason lays out the
system is
broken anyone can report abuse they can
do it anonymously they can do it as many
times as they want and all reports are
investigated no matter how obviously
frivolous they are
um this was um this was a report
based on a publicly available internet
post
okay the people calling cps on bean dad
they were doing it based on a tweet
there is no good reason for the
government to respond to that at
all if we allow just a little bit of
judgment and discretion then cps could
have
looked at the report looked at the tweet
in question
and said never mind this is absurd oh
that's what you're calling about that
what no we're not gonna we're not gonna
go knock on the guy's door
but instead everything these days
especially in government
operates according to the zero tolerance
policy the dear
the zero tolerance sort of philosophy
and what that means is that all
situations will be treated
exactly the same no discernment no
discretion no
human judgment will enter the equation
at all we are we are to act as robots
um according to the programming
the reason article references a report
in the new york daily news that's
very relevant here it says quote over
the past 40 years more and more people
have been calling the child abuse
hotlines
not because there's so much child abuse
going on but because they've been
conditioned to report
almost anything a kid with a scrape a
kid walking the dog
as possible abuse or neglect better safe
than sorry
but how safe how sorry according to one
estimate more than half of all
african-american children 53 will be
visited by child protective services at
some point their childhood that compared
to 37 percent of all children
which is already outrageous now 37
of all children sounds
enormously high um i i i almost have to
doubt that it could pot
37 maybe that is as bad as it's gotten
all told it says 7.8 million kids get
reported to child protective services
each year and that is literally seven
million kids too many
the mind-bogglingly vast majority of
calls turn out to be to not be cases of
abuse and neglect at all
while tragically child abuse and neglect
deaths do occur
these cases represent two out of every
one hundred thousand hotline calls
two out of one hundred and thousand
um and as the number of calls has gone
up in the last few two decades the
number of deaths has not gone down
that's right abuse deaths increased
possibly because caseworkers are
stretched so
thin the important thing to remember
here
is that all of these millions of
frivolous child abuse reports and
investigations are not
victimless it's not like nobody is hurt
by just checking on the claim
right better safe than sorry no that's
that's not always
the case but it's a frivolous child
abuse
claim or or report and then
this innocent parent ends up in the
crosshairs
of cps and their parental rights are on
the line and there
they could possibly lose their parental
rights and lose their children
even though they didn't do anything
wrong that is not better safe than sorry
lots of families are hurt destroyed
ripped apart
once the parents become officially
suspected child abusers
uh that's what happens the system is
indeed broken
fixing it will be complicated work but
one thing that's needed in order to fix
it is a return to
situational judgment discretion
not treating everything the same as
everything else
not all child abuse reports are made are
are created equal they're not all the
same
okay a kid goes to school and he's
got you know he's got very suspicious
looking brugit bruises or he looks to be
malnourished or something like that
you know that's clearly you you call cps
for that
but someone since writes a tweet about
their kid opening a can of beans
or you see an eight-year-old that was
allowed to go down to the playground
you know 100 yards from the house by
himself
walk the dog down the street he's got a
scrape on his knee no
those are not the same so this is one
thing
situational judgment discretion
letting human beings discern and make
judgments based on based on that
not all child abuse reports are created
equal the bean dad case
shows that as so many other cases show
that as well and that's why
the people who reported being dead are
officially
cancelled listen hit that subscribe
button
right now do it right now i thank you
for your compliance
it is somewhat appreciated